joining us in the studio is dr. Simone
Ibaka from the German academic exchange
service now we've seen integration kind
of seem to fail with that Egyptian as
scientists can you understand her
feelings yes I can I mean obviously she
she's homesick and she is feeling about
integrated maybe at university because
in universities international places
well I complain about the university too
that's actually interesting because what
we have seen is that scientists and also
students I feel quite well integrated
and universities because they are very
welcome to their students they have our
consent they speak English but what we
observe that the problems are keep in
everyday lives do ordinary people how do
they react to find people usually don't
have problems with people from abroad
sometimes they may be seen if it's cold
not so easy to to to speak to and that
mind gives them the feeling that they
are not welcome which actually might not
be the case okay so we maybe should
improve our welcoming culture and start
to hug people that come into the country
maybe we should just invite them in our
houses well you actually participated in
the actual report on academic exchange
and student mobility it's called
business after very often so science
world wide open
was there an exception with the Egyptian
scientist or is that the normal
situation that scientists usually leave
after a few years again we don't have
really good figures for scientists a lot
of them stay some go but we don't find
that as a problem because what we
actually want to enable is as
corporations or actually we find it good
if people go and come back and they
really have exchange we have quite a
good figures for foreign students and we
know that half of the foreign students
actually stay after they finish their
studies in Germany despite the situation
that it's not so easy for junior
scientists to actually get postdoc
positions and make a career in Germany
science yeah that's right but if you
speak about foreign students I mean they
are not all going into into science but
also in in other in in and other
companies or do other things what about
the students from Germany actually going
abroad I read in your report that it's
about one-third of all German students
going for some time for their studies
abroad that seems like a low number
isn't it I think it's not I mean if you
compare the two other countries for
example for us our Western countries
number is quite high but still we want
to improve that so our goal and also the
goal for our government is to waste the
this figure that every second German
student goes about now it's
understandable that all the countries
are actually competing for the best
heads in science Germany seems to be on
the good side in this game but poorer
countries might not be able to keep up
with the situation and lose heads and
also might lose their future in this
case
I mean how to deal with the problem yeah
that's that's really appropriate
specially for very poor countries like
for example in Africa we can do that
that we try in the situation of quaint
Iranian supreme circulation which means
that also scientists from abroad
keep in touch with that country and what
we do with our scholarship programs for
students and researchers from developing
country that our programs are designed
that these people actually go back
thanks not for the talks